hi I'm Alec Steiner and today we're
going to go and meet one of my favorite
youtubers Estee lalande we're gonna have
a little look at her wardrobe her makeup
sash talk about her new book bloom and
of course meet Reggie hello welcome to
my living room oh my god it's so bright
yes I love that there's like literally
windows everywhere that's like my big
thing cuz I get a little sad in the
British weather sometimes I mean I got
the real thing ya know absolutely that
what inspires me like when you got this
house what where did you look like did
you look on websites did you have your
endurance race well I have to say a lot
of it is my boyfriend Aslan he's really
good at designing so for instance our
table that we have right here he
designed it himself and he had it made
but the entire idea was his own he does
have a bit of a creative vision that
needs to get flushed out sometime so I'm
happy because it makes our house really
unique and we have things that we both
really love but I have to have my little
touches you know like I have to have my
ceramics and my little pastel balls is
and stuff no I think our space is quite
equal feels really comfy but open let's
get comfortable
so obviously I want to talk about your
new book yeah loom I was really
surprised in a pleasant way about how
open you were and I just wonder if
that's something that as you were
writing it if that was something that
you were kind of conscious about of how
much you were going to open up for me
the book was really a place to be open
because you can only be so open in a ten
minute video you know I think probably
something that you know the glamour
readers and also your viewers will be
interested in is the body image aspect
because also that's something that
resonates in my life and I think a lot
of you know girls go through that I knew
I was going to talk about it but it was
just about how I was going to talk about
it and when I was writing bloom I tried
to reflect a lot and you know it's hard
to kind of go back into those memories
of you as a teenager and feel those hard
times that you went through but I really
mentally tried to do that it's important
to see that you know people do go
through things you know we went through
things it actually made me feel made me
remember things in my life and well
that's your point yeah so we're gonna go
and have a look at your closet yes we
are a little make-up but yes let's go
I really want to know how do you shop so
I do shop mostly online but but but but
I had a little revelation shopping in
real life is so good ok I know it seems
kind of revelation ok you can be so much
more inspired by knows like for instance
this sweater I swear I'm not just
mentioning it because it's the bloom the
bloom sweater ok talk to me like what
you've done there didn't mean to but I
would never buy this like online I
bought it I never in a million years but
I saw it I was like ok I tried it out I
was like I don't hate this can you tell
us like some some bits here that you're
loving like for autumn dressing for
autumn is the best yes in my favor I
love it um so right now I'm especially
loving this Isabel Marant blazer oh it's
about like a jacket blazer yes you know
it's beautiful she cuts so beautifully
and is there anything in your wardrobe
that you know you literally have never
worn yes loads of things but this I've
never worn tag still on it this is like
a trouser and like shirt set which looks
insane it's like very alien II I still
think it could be cool you're looking at
it like don't know no I'm not making
yeah and I'm thinking how long have you
had it in your clothes like two or three
years right yeah I'm never gonna wear I
know I'll wear these like in the daytime
or whatever love those trainers I love
like a pair of flats like these which
are a little more special you know you
can kind of like tie them up they have
an interesting print there beautiful
statement flat yeah they're gorgeous
gorgeous yeah Gucci's I love them as
well as when like hates them whenever I
read I don't know he just thinks they're
really ugly but I love them I know
they're not a boy they're not a boy sexy
coming yeah
don't care
[Music]
okay so this is where the real magic
happens Alex I love it this is where I
come to be Zen I mean can I just say can
I come and work here please sure anytime
let's just open up the drawers right oh
don't open that one oh this is my time
to like really shine loads of stuff yeah
tons of drawers yes so basically when
something new comes in a right by
something yeah I immediately put it in
my I like the look of it I'll put it in
my everyday makeup drawers which I know
this is a lot of makeup for every day
but this is where I do my makeup in our
world to get it right you actually never
looked like you have makeup on it's like
people say to you you look great but
people don't say it wouldn't say to you
like your cake yeah that's an aesthetic
that I quite love but you think did you
think you used to wear more don't you
know I used to wear like full coverage
foundations you know stuff like that so
now I'm so talk to us a few products
that you really do care about the first
thing I'm obsessed with is this oh my
god it's the best eyelash curler ever
it's choice Roth's eyelash curler I've
been dying to buy that one I haven't
bought it yet tell me I should buy it
yeah there you go tip for today oh good
I love it I love this brand too much I
never have say a leaf ah you say that I
say Ellis far I look I have no idea
either
I don't really know it's like very crazy
contraption but it's lipsticks and lip
products so I love do you think they're
super cool and I love the packaging yeah
that's really cool
concealer go to always by Terry I love
that one is that Ben filleth yes that's
my favorite concealer only for under the
eyes though yeah doesn't really cover
like blemishes that well but I love for
under the eyes what blemishes layer
there finally I want to ask you can you
if you're gonna give some advice to some
of the glamour readers for watching this
you want to do what you do if you think
back you know when you started cuz
you've been doing this for like 60 over
six years now what are some little
pieces of advice you would give them I
mean the first thing is just start now
pay attention to what everyone else is
doing you can look at it and
I earn it but just think about what
would you want to read what are you find
interesting and just kind of keep you
know it really in tune with that that's
very helpful thank you so much ese for
inviting us into your beautiful home I
want to move in thank you for coming you
can move in Oh temporarily it's great
yeah so thank you so much for coming I
had so much fun for more cool videos
like this make sure you subscribe to
glamour UK